สวัสดี ฉันชื่อ Olivia Lan เป็นนักวิจัยและนักการศึกษาที่ IBM Quantum วิดีโอนี้เป็นการเปิดตัวซีรีส์
ใหม่บนช่อง YouTube ของ Qiskit และแพลตฟอร์มการเรียนรู้ของเรา ชื่อว่า Quantum Computing in
Practice หรือเรียกสั้น ๆ ว่า ในซีรีส์นี้ฉันจะแสดงวิธีใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมที่มีอยู่จริงตอนนี้ให้ได้
ศักยภาพเต็มที่ มีวิดีโอหลายพันล้านอยู่บนอินเทอร์เน็ตเกี่ยวกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมและศักยภาพในอนาคต หรือแนวคิดเชิงทฤษฎี
เบื้องหลังการคำนวณควอนตัม ซึ่งสำคัญไม่แพ้กัน ลองดู Understanding Quantum Information and Computation
โดย John Watrous เป็นตัวอย่าง แต่ในคอร์สนี้เราจะสมมติว่าผู้เรียนอาจรู้มากกว่า
ที่เราเคยสอนมาก่อนหน้านี้ และเราจะไปไกลมากในเชิงเทคนิค เพราะในช่วงปีที่ผ่านมา และ
ขณะที่บันทึกวิดีโอนี้คือปี 2024 เราได้เห็นการเปลี่ยนแปลง การเปลี่ยนเฟสก็ว่าได้ สู่ยุคใหม่ของ
การคำนวณ คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมกำลังเข้าใกล้จุดที่มีประโยชน์ได้จริง แม้ว่าการทดลองกับ
circuit ขนาดเล็กและคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจะจำเป็นต่อการให้ความรู้ชุมชนของเรา แต่ไม่มีใครรันการทดลอง
ที่ทำไม่ได้บนคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกธรรมดา แต่ตอนนี้เราเข้าสู่ยุคของ
quantum utility หรือประโยชน์ใช้สอยควอนตัม แล้ว utility คืออะไร มันต่างจาก Quantum Advantage ซึ่งเข้าใจได้ที่
จุดที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมทำได้ดีกว่าคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกในงานที่มีความหมาย แต่ utility หมายถึง
สามารถเริ่มแข่งขันกันได้ และนี่คือก้าวถัดไปตามธรรมชาติใน
วิวัฒนาการทางเทคโนโลยี IBM เผยแพร่งานวิจัยที่แสดงว่าครั้งแรกเมื่อปีที่แล้ว คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสามารถใช้
จำลองแบบจำลองทางฟิสิกส์และแข่งขันกับเทคนิคการจำลองแบบคลาสสิกที่ล้ำที่สุด มันยังทำได้ดีกว่า
วิธี Brute Force และเปิดแนวทางใหม่ให้นักวิจัยใช้ในการวิจัย แล้วทำไมทั้งหมดนี้ถึงเกิดขึ้น
ตอนนี้? ในช่วงไม่กี่เดือนที่ผ่านมา IBM ได้เปิดให้ใช้โปรเซสเซอร์ควอนตัมที่มีมากกว่า 100 qubit อย่างแพร่หลาย ถ้า
คุณเป็นผู้ใช้อยู่แล้ว อาจสังเกตว่าเราถอดโปรเซสเซอร์ขนาดเล็กออกหลายตัวเพื่อเปิดทางให้ชิปขนาดใหญ่เหล่านี้ และเราคิดว่ามันสำคัญ
มากที่ต้องทำแบบนั้น เพราะ qubit จำนวนหนึ่งยังสามารถจำลองแบบคลาสสิกได้โดยไม่มีปัญหา ดังนั้น
ไม่มีข้อได้เปรียบจริง ๆ ที่ได้จากการใช้ชิปเหล่านั้น แต่ที่ 100 qubit นั้นไม่ใช่กรณีนั้นอีกต่อไป
จำลองแบบคลาสสิกไม่ได้แล้ว สิ่งสำคัญอีกอย่างคือมีสิ่งที่เรียกว่า simulator ซึ่ง
เป็นโปรแกรมคอมพิวเตอร์ที่สามารถจำลองพฤติกรรมบางอย่างของระบบควอนตัม รวมถึง noise แต่โปรด
อย่าลืมว่าฉันพูดว่า "จำลอง" simulator ไม่ใช่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม มันไม่สามารถให้ผลลัพธ์ที่
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมทำได้ในระดับนี้ แต่ก็ยังเป็นส่วนสำคัญของกระบวนการทดสอบของเรา นั่นเป็น
คำตอบที่ยาวมากสำหรับคำถามที่ด้านบนของสไลด์นี้ Quantum Computing เชิงปฏิบัติคืออะไร ในคอร์สนี้ฉันจะสอนเกี่ยวกับ
use case ที่มีศักยภาพจริงของควอนตัม และแนวทางที่ดีที่สุดในการรันและทดลองบนโปรเซสเซอร์ขนาดใหญ่
เหล่านี้ในปัจจุบัน แล้วคอร์สนี้มุ่งเป้าไปที่ใคร มาเริ่มต้นด้วยการกำหนดระดับกันก่อน
ในตอนแรก คอร์สนี้สำหรับทุกคนที่ต้องการพัฒนาแอปพลิเคชันใหม่สำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม อยากรู้วิธี
ขยายงานที่ทำอยู่หรือเรียนรู้วิธีใช้ควอนตัมในเวิร์กโฟลว์ที่มีอยู่ ฉันพูดถึงก่อนหน้านี้ว่า
คอร์สนี้จะลงมือปฏิบัติมาก และจะไม่พูดถึงแง่มุมเชิงทฤษฎีมากนัก
เราคาดว่าคุณจะมีความเข้าใจพื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับการคำนวณควอนตัม แต่ถ้ายังไม่ถึงตรงนั้น ไม่ต้องกังวล แค่ดู
สองสามตอนแรกของคอร์ส John Watrous แล้วคุณจะพร้อม เราอยากให้ผู้ชมรู้ว่า
คอร์สนี้ไม่ได้มีแค่สำหรับนักฟิสิกส์หรือนักวิทยาศาสตร์คอมพิวเตอร์ สองสาขานี้
ครองวงการ Quantum Computing มานานเกือบสิบปีแล้ว เราอยากให้คนอื่นที่ทำงานกับ big data หรือ
การจำลอง เช่น วิศวกร นักเคมี และนักวิทยาศาสตร์วัสดุ รู้ว่าคอร์สนี้มีไว้สำหรับพวกเขาด้วย โดยสรุป
คอร์สนี้มุ่งสู่ผู้ชมในวงกว้าง และหวังว่าคุณจะร่วมเรียนกับเราตลอดทั้งคอร์ส เมื่อเรียนจบคุณ
จะเข้าใจวิธีสร้างและรัน utility scale job ผ่าน Qiskit runtime รวมถึงเวิร์กโฟลว์ทั้งหมด
คุณจะเข้าใจประเภทหลักของ error mitigation และเข้าใจพื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันที่มีแนวโน้มในระยะสั้น คุณยังจะสามารถ
รันอัลกอริทึมเหล่านี้ทั้งหมดใน Qiskit และสุดท้ายเราคาดว่าคุณจะเข้าใจ noise และวิธีจัดการกับมัน
งั้นมาเริ่มกันเลย Quantum Computing เป็นเทคโนโลยีใหม่ที่น่าตื่นเต้นในช่วงเริ่มต้นของการพัฒนา แต่นี่แค่
บทหนึ่งในเรื่องราวของการคำนวณที่ย้อนหลังไปหลายพันปี ฉันคิดว่าสำคัญที่ต้องเข้าใจ
บริบทนี้ เพราะมันทำให้สิ่งที่เราต้องการทำที่นี่เข้าใจง่ายขึ้น คาดเดาได้มากขึ้น และดูไม่เหมือน
นิยายวิทยาศาสตร์ นับตั้งแต่สมัยโบราณ เราในฐานะมนุษย์จำเป็นต้องทำการคำนวณ หรือ
พูดอีกอย่างคือประมวลผลข้อมูลตามกฎและข้อจำกัดบางอย่าง เพื่อให้สามารถ
สื่อสาร ก่อสร้าง ทำการค้า วิทยาศาสตร์ และทุกด้านของชีวิตเรา เราหันไปพึ่งโลกกายภาพ
เพื่อขอความช่วยเหลือ และผ่านการค้นพบที่ชาญฉลาด เราสร้างอุปกรณ์เพื่อช่วยคำนวณ ในสมัยก่อน อุปกรณ์ทำจาก
ไม้ กระดูก เชือกผูกปม และเก็บข้อมูลและช่วยการคำนวณต่างจากที่เราทำ
ในปัจจุบัน อุปกรณ์เชิงกลที่สร้างจากคันโยก เฟือง และเครื่องจักรอื่น ๆ พัฒนาจากนาฬิกาดาราศาสตร์ยุคแรก ไปสู่
เครื่องคิดเลข ไปสู่อุปกรณ์คำนวณที่ซับซ้อน เช่น differential analyzer ที่แก้สมการโดยใช้ล้อและ
แผ่นหมุน แม้แต่เทคโนโลยีการเขียนก็มีบทบาทสำคัญในเรื่องราวนี้ โดยช่วยให้ผู้คนทำ
การคำนวณที่ทำไม่ได้มาก่อน เมื่อเราคิดถึงคอมพิวเตอร์ในปัจจุบัน เรามักนึกถึง
คอมพิวเตอร์ดิจิทัลอิเล็กทรอนิกส์ แต่นี่เป็นเทคโนโลยีที่ค่อนข้างใหม่ คอมพิวเตอร์ดิจิทัลอิเล็กทรอนิกส์
ถูกสร้างครั้งแรกในทศวรรษ 1940s เครื่องมือคำนวณที่เก่าแก่ที่สุดที่รู้จักจริง ๆ คือลูกคิดของชาวสุเมเรียน
ซึ่งผู้เชี่ยวชาญเชื่อว่าถูกประดิษฐ์ขึ้นในบาบิโลนราว 2700–2300 ปีก่อนคริสตกาล นั่นนานมาก
มากเลย แต่เราได้เข้าใจโลกธรรมชาติมากขึ้นเรื่อย ๆ ตั้งแต่ Archimedes จนถึง Euclid ถึง
Einstein ความต้องการทรัพยากรการคำนวณของเราพุ่งสูงขึ้นอย่างมาก วันนี้เรามีซูเปอร์คอมพิวเตอร์ ซึ่งโดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือ
คอมพิวเตอร์ที่ทรงพลังมาก ๆ หลายเครื่องเชื่อมกันแบบ parallel พวกมันเป็นหนึ่งในเครื่องมือที่ดีที่สุดของมนุษยชาติในการ
แก้ปัญหาที่ยาก แต่ก็ยังมีปัญหามากมายที่แม้แต่ยักษ์ใหญ่แห่งคอมพิวเตอร์เหล่านี้ก็ไม่มีวัน
แก้ได้ เรื่องนี้จะพูดถึงอีกทีในภายหลัง ดังนั้นเราได้สรุปแล้วว่ามนุษย์ใช้ฟิสิกส์และธรรมชาติช่วยเราคำนวณ
มาหลายพันปี และเพื่อช่วยเราในการค้นหาไม่รู้จบที่จะคำนวณมากขึ้นและใหญ่ขึ้น คุณอาจ
คุ้นเคยกับกฎของ Moore แต่จริง ๆ แล้วมันไม่ใช่กฎเสียทีเดียว มันเป็นการสังเกต ส่วน "กฎ" นั้นเป็นสำนวน
ตลก ๆ ในความเห็นฉัน จำนวนสูงสุดของทรานซิสเตอร์ในวงจรรวม หรือโดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือชิปคอมพิวเตอร์
จะเพิ่มขึ้นสองเท่าประมาณทุก 2 ปี ในช่วง 5 ทศวรรษที่ผ่านมา เราไม่ได้แค่สังเกตสิ่งนี้แต่ยังใช้ประโยชน์จากมันอย่างมาก
ด้วยทรานซิสเตอร์มากขึ้น เราทำการคำนวณได้มากขึ้นและเร็วขึ้น นี่คือสิ่งที่รับผิดชอบ
ทำให้คอมพิวเตอร์ทรงพลังมากขึ้นและเล็กลงเรื่อย ๆ แต่มีข่าวร้าย กฎของ Moore กำลังจะตาย
ผู้เชี่ยวชาญไม่เห็นด้วยกันว่ากฎของ Moore จะสิ้นสุดเมื่อไหร่ บางคนบอกว่ามันจบแล้ว แม้ว่าเราอาจ
ไม่แน่ใจว่าเมื่อไหร่จะถึงขีดจำกัด เราก็รู้ว่ามันเลี่ยงไม่ได้ในที่สุด เพราะชิ้นส่วนทรานซิสเตอร์บางอย่าง
ไม่สามารถทำให้เล็กลงทางฟิสิกส์ได้อีกแล้ว คุณทำทรานซิสเตอร์ที่เล็กกว่าอะตอมไม่ได้ นี่
เป็นเรื่องที่ผิดทางฟิสิกส์โดยสิ้นเชิง ฟังดูตลก แต่นั่นคือขีดจำกัดที่เรากำลังทำงานด้วย แล้วเรา
จะทำอะไร ยอมแพ้แล้วบอกว่าดีแค่นี้แล้วเหรอ? ไม่ มนุษย์ไม่เคยทำแบบนั้น โชคดีที่กลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
เข้ามาในบทสนทนา กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมถูกค้นพบในทศวรรษ 1920s และตั้งแต่นั้นมาโลก
ก็ไม่เหมือนเดิมอีกต่อไป และเราสามารถใช้เวลาหลายชั่วโมงพูดถึงการค้นพบที่ปฏิวัติวงการ
แต่นั่นไม่ใช่จุดมุ่งหมายของคอร์สนี้ แต่ฉันอยากให้ชัดเจนว่าเรารู้ว่ากลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
และการคำนวณเข้ากันได้อยู่แล้ว สิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้จากกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมเกี่ยวกับธรรมชาติ
มีส่วนทำให้คอมพิวเตอร์สมัยใหม่เป็นไปได้ ถ้าไม่มีกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
เราคงไม่เข้าใจหรืออาจแม้แต่ประดิษฐ์ฮาร์ดดิสก์แบบ solid state ได้
ยกตัวอย่างเช่น การคำนวณควอนตัมเป็นเพียงก้าวถัดไปตามธรรมชาติในวิวัฒนาการนี้
แต่การคำนวณไม่ได้อยู่แค่ในสุญญากาศ ข้อมูลต้องการสื่อกลาง
การประมวลผลข้อมูลใช้ประโยชน์จากโลกกายภาพและส่งผลต่อมันด้วย สิ่งนี้กำหนดข้อจำกัดว่าอะไรเป็นไปได้ทางฟิสิกส์
แต่การทำความเข้าใจธรรมชาติและข้อจำกัดทางฟิสิกส์คือเป้าหมายของฟิสิกส์ในฐานะ
วิชา ดังนั้นในแง่หนึ่ง ฟิสิกส์และการคำนวณเชื่อมโยงกันเสมอมา Ralph Landauer นักวิทยาศาสตร์คอมพิวเตอร์และ
นักวิจัยของ IBM ตระหนักเมื่อหลายทศวรรษก่อนว่าข้อมูลคือฟิสิกส์ พูดอีกทางหนึ่ง ข้อมูลไม่ใช่
สิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรม แต่มีอยู่ผ่านการแสดงออกทางกายภาพเท่านั้น หลักการของ Landauer สร้างความเชื่อมโยง
ระหว่างข้อมูลกับกฎของอุณหพลศาสตร์ แต่จริง ๆ แล้วมีความเชื่อมโยงมากมายระหว่างฟิสิกส์และ
การคำนวณ ฟิสิกส์แบบคลาสสิกเป็นสิ่งเดียวที่เราสำรวจได้จนเมื่อเร็ว ๆ นี้ แต่ด้วยการค้นพบกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
เราอยู่บนขอบของการสร้างวิธีการคำนวณแบบใหม่ทั้งหมด และนี่ดีมาก เพราะ
คอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกทำได้แค่ประมาณค่าสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นจริงในธรรมชาติ และในบางกรณีการประมาณนั้น
จำกัดมาก เพราะมันยากมากที่จะให้เครื่องที่เป็นไปตามกฎของฟิสิกส์แบบคลาสสิก
ประมาณค่ากฎของฟิสิกส์ควอนตัม และธรรมชาติไม่ใช่คลาสสิก มันเป็นควอนตัม อุปมาที่อาจช่วยให้คุณ
เข้าใจคือ wind tunnel กลศาสตร์ของไหลเป็นเรื่องที่ยากมากในการจำลองและทำนายทางคณิตศาสตร์
แม้แต่สิ่งธรรมดาอย่างรถที่วิ่งฝ่าลม ผู้ผลิตรถยนต์พบว่ามันแพงเกินไปและไม่ปฏิบัติจริง
ที่จะลองจำลองปฏิสัมพันธ์ทางฟิสิกส์นี้ขณะออกแบบรถ แทนที่จะทำแบบนั้น
สิ่งที่ทำแทนคือสร้างอุโมงค์จริง ๆ ที่เป่าลมผ่าน แล้วขับรถเข้าไปในอุโมงค์
และดูว่ามันทำงานอย่างไร นี่เหมือนกับสิ่งที่ฉันหมายถึงเมื่อบอกว่าคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกทำได้แค่
ประมาณค่าธรรมชาติได้ไม่ดี และบางครั้งมันแพงเกินไปที่จะให้มันทำ แทนที่จะจำลองลม
นักวิจัยก็แค่สร้างมันขึ้นมาใหม่ ในทำนองเดียวกัน คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมไม่ต้องประมาณกฎธรรมชาติใน
ระดับโมเลกุล เพราะมันทำตามกฎเหล่านั้นโดยธรรมชาติ มันไม่ต้องจำลองอะไร มันเลียนแบบมัน และ
ความยากเดียวกันเกิดขึ้นเมื่อเราจำลองแบตเตอรี่หรือปฏิกิริยาเคมี ซึ่งนำเราไปสู่ส่วนถัดไป
Quantum Computing ดีสำหรับอะไร
ทำไมเราถึงอยากลองรวมกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมกับการคำนวณ? มีปัญหามากมาย
ที่ยากเกินไป มีต้นทุนการคำนวณสูงเกินไปสำหรับแม้แต่ซูเปอร์คอมพิวเตอร์ที่ล้ำที่สุดของเรา
อาจเป็นปัญหาที่มีแค่นักวิจัยที่โฟกัสมาก แต่ผลกระทบอาจแตะทุกส่วน
ของโลก ปัญหาที่คอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกติดขัด เป็นสิ่งที่สังคมเราพึ่งพาเทคโนโลยีมากขึ้น
และใส่ใจ เช่น ประสิทธิภาพแบตเตอรี่ การสร้างแบบจำลองทางการเงินและ
การออปติไมซ์ และแม้แต่วิธีสร้างเครื่องบินที่ดีกว่า แล้วทำไมต้องหันมาใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม? เรามีเหตุผลดีมาก
ที่คิดว่ามีศักยภาพมาก และเราสามารถเปิดประตูสู่การคำนวณแบบใหม่ที่อยู่นอกเหนือการเข้าถึงแม้แต่
ซูเปอร์คอมพิวเตอร์ที่ทรงพลังที่สุดในทางทฤษฎี อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมบางอย่างให้ข้อได้เปรียบเหนือ
อัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกที่ดีที่สุดที่เป็นไปได้สำหรับบางแอปพลิเคชัน สำหรับแอปพลิเคชันอื่น มีหลักฐานมากขึ้นว่าแม้
มี noise และความไม่สมบูรณ์ คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมยังสามารถใช้เป็นเครื่องมือแข่งขันกับ Brute
Force แบบคลาสสิกได้ โดยพื้นฐานแล้วมันเป็นเครื่องมือใหม่ทั้งหมด และเราต้องการค้นหาสิ่งเจ๋ง ๆ ที่ทำได้มากขึ้น แต่เรายัง
สามารถมองย้อนไปที่ไอเดียดั้งเดิมของ Feynman สำหรับมัน คือใช้มันเพื่อทำความเข้าใจฟิสิกส์และธรรมชาติในตัวเอง
ท้ายที่สุด ฉันบอกแล้วว่าธรรมชาติเป็นควอนตัม ไม่ใช่คลาสสิก และสาขานี้น่าทึ่ง น่าหลงใหล และ
สหสาขาวิชามาก มันรวมฟิสิกส์ วิทยาศาสตร์คอมพิวเตอร์ การประมวลผลข้อมูล และแน่นอนสาขาแอปพลิเคชัน
เฉพาะที่เราสนใจ อย่างไรก็ตาม ต่างจากคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก ไม่ใช่ทุกคนมีคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมใส่กระเป๋า
จนเมื่อไม่นานมานี้ ถ้าอยากทดลองกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ต้องสร้างและดูแลรักษา
ด้วยตัวเอง ปกติในห้องแล็บชั้นใต้ดินที่น่าเศร้าในมหาวิทยาลัยหรือสถาบันวิจัย และเชื่อฉันเถอะ ฉันรู้ดี แต่นั้น
ไม่ใช่กรณีอีกต่อไปแล้ว ในปี 2016 IBM นำโปรเซสเซอร์ควอนตัมตัวแรกขึ้นคลาวด์ มีเพียงห้า qubit ตอนนั้น และ
อัตรา error ค่อนข้างสูง แต่นั่นแค่ 8 ปีที่แล้ว และดูว่าเราก้าวมาไกลแค่ไหน แล้วตอนนี้เราอยู่ตรงไหน?
มีความเหมือนมากมายกับยุคต้นของคอมพิวเตอร์สมัยใหม่ อย่างที่บอก นี่เป็นความ
ท้าทายที่ยากมาก และเพิ่งในช่วง 8 ปีที่ผ่านมาที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเปิดให้ใช้งานอย่างแพร่หลาย นอกจาก
สำหรับผู้ที่ทำงานในแล็บหรือสถาบันล้ำยุค แต่ในช่วงแปดปีที่ผ่านมาเราได้พัฒนาในทุก
ด้าน โปรเซสเซอร์มีขนาด qubit ใหญ่กว่าหลายเท่า gate ดีขึ้นมาก และเราได้แนะนำวิธี
ลดหรือบรรเทา error ที่มีอยู่โดยธรรมชาติในระบบควอนตัม แม้ขณะเราเดินหน้าสร้าง fault
tolerant quantum computer ตอนนี้คุณและทุกคนสามารถใช้โปรเซสเซอร์ IBM Quantum มากมายที่
โฮสต์บนคลาวด์ได้ เกือบทั้งหมดเป็นระบบใหม่ล่าสุดที่ดีที่สุด มีมากกว่า 100
qubit แต่ขนาดของโปรเซสเซอร์ไม่ใช่สิ่งเดียวที่สำคัญ นี่เป็นแค่ metric เดียวที่เราสนใจ
และมันสมเหตุสมผล ถ้ามี qubit มากขึ้นก็ดีกว่าอย่างชัดเจน หากการเพิ่ม qubit
ไม่ทำให้ประสิทธิภาพลดลง แต่นั่นไม่ได้เป็นแบบนั้นเสมอ เราต้องการ qubit คุณภาพดีที่ไม่รบกวนกัน
ผ่าน cross talk เมื่อเราไม่ต้องการ วิธีที่ qubit เชื่อมต่อกันก็เป็นเรื่องสำคัญที่ต้องคำนึงถึงใน
superconducting circuit เป็นความท้าทายที่จะหาวิธีเชื่อมต่อ qubit ทางกายภาพให้ดีที่สุด อีก metric สำคัญมาก
คือ two qubit gate fidelity gate ที่รันบน qubit เดี่ยวไม่ค่อยเกิด error two qubit gate เป็น
พื้นที่ที่น่าเป็นห่วงมากกว่า และมักเป็น metric หลักที่เราดูเพื่อดูว่าประสิทธิภาพพัฒนาขึ้นอย่างไร
two qubit gate สำคัญมากที่ต้องทำให้ถูกต้อง เพราะมันรับผิดชอบการสร้าง entanglement ระหว่าง qubit
ซึ่งเป็นหนึ่งในปรากฏการณ์ฟิสิกส์ที่ให้พลังงานแก่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม สุดท้ายเราดู Speed และประสิทธิภาพ
เราต้องแน่ใจว่าเวลาที่ใช้รันโปรแกรมบนชิปควอนตัมทำได้เร็วและมีประสิทธิภาพ
ที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้ เราเรียก metric ทั้งสามนี้รวมกันว่า scale, quality และ
speed ทั้งหมดมีความสำคัญในการพัฒนาประสิทธิภาพ ตอนนี้อยากแสดงกราฟด่วนเพื่อสนับสนุนสิ่งที่พูดมา
เกี่ยวกับเทคโนโลยีที่พัฒนาอย่างรวดเร็วจริง ๆ จำนวน qubit เองเข้าใจได้ง่ายที่สุด
ฉันคิด และ IBM เผยแพร่แผนงานว่าหวังจะอยู่ตรงไหนในช่วงไม่กี่ปีข้างหน้าในแง่ของจำนวน qubit
และขนาดโปรเซสเซอร์ สำหรับปี 2024 ที่เรากำลังถ่ายทำวิดีโอนี้ เราอยู่ในเส้นทางกับโปรเซสเซอร์ Heron และ Condor ถัดไป
คุณภาพ กราฟนี้แสดง median entangling gate error rate ของโปรเซสเซอร์ IBM Quantum ตามเวลา ต้องจำไว้
ว่านี่เป็นสเกล log ดังนั้นแม้ความคืบหน้าจะดูเป็นเส้นตรงประมาณ แต่จริง ๆ มันรวดเร็วกว่านั้นมาก
สุดท้ายมี speed กราฟนี้แสดงความคืบหน้าของ metric ที่เราเรียกว่า CLOPS ซึ่งย่อมาจาก circuit layer
operations per second สิ่งสำคัญคือ CLOPS ครอบคลุมทั้งเวลาในการรัน circuit และ real-time
classical compute ที่ต้องการ โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว CLOPS คือการวัดว่าโปรเซสเซอร์ของเรารัน circuit เฉพาะ
ต่อเนื่องได้เร็วแค่ไหน ทำหน้าที่เป็นตัววัดความเร็วของระบบโดยรวม รวมทั้งควอนตัมและคลาสสิก
ตอนนี้ ณ เวลาที่บันทึก IBM เป็นผู้ให้บริการ Quantum cloud เดียวที่ให้เข้าถึง 100
qubit ขึ้นไปตามที่ฉันพูดถึงก่อนหน้า 100 qubit หรือประมาณนั้นคือที่การจำลองแบบคลาสสิก
เริ่มล้มเหลวสมบูรณ์ ดังนั้น large scale job ที่รันบนเครื่องเหล่านี้มักไม่มี classical equivalent มัน
ทำไม่ได้ มีความละเอียดอ่อนและเคล็ดลับที่สามารถเล่นเพื่อจำลองบางส่วนของ circuit และส่วนอื่น
แยกกัน แต่โดยทั่วไปเรารู้ว่าประมาณตัวเลขนี้คือที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเริ่มทำสิ่งที่คลาสสิกทำไม่ได้
IBM จึงตัดสินใจว่าการให้เข้าถึงอุปกรณ์ขนาดใหญ่เหล่านี้สำคัญมากสำหรับชุมชนวงกว้าง เพราะทุกอย่าง
ที่ทำบนอุปกรณ์ขนาดเล็กนั้น simulatable แบบคลาสสิกได้ ดังนั้นมันนำไปสู่ Quantum Advantage ไม่ได้ 100 qubit
อุปกรณ์ที่เรามีตอนนี้ยังมีข้อบกพร่องและ noisy อยู่ ดังนั้นเราต้องฉลาดเกี่ยวกับวิธีรัน job และ
circuit บนมัน การแค่เขียน circuit แล้วกด shift+enter อย่างไม่ระมัดระวังก็ไม่น่าจะนำไปสู่อะไรที่
น่าประทับใจ แต่อีกครั้ง มีเคล็ดลับและแนวทางที่ดีที่สุดที่เราสามารถปฏิบัติตามเพื่อดึง
ประสิทธิภาพมากขึ้นจากอุปกรณ์เหล่านี้ ซึ่งหวังว่าจะนำไปสู่ Quantum Advantage เร็วขึ้น แม้ขณะเราดำเนิน
การสร้าง fault tolerant machine ด้วย กราฟนี้แสดงต้นทุนการจำลอง
หรือเวลาที่ใช้แก้ปัญหาบนคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกและคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมที่ติดตั้ง error
mitigation และ error correction เส้น classical computation scale แบบ exponential ตาม circuit complexity
สำหรับ circuit ง่าย ๆ ที่นี่ไม่สำคัญ แต่มันแย่อย่างชัดเจนเมื่อ complexity เพิ่มขึ้น เพราะมัน
ทำให้ต้นทุนการจำลองแพงมากอย่างรวดเร็ว error mitigation scale ดีกว่า ดังนั้นเมื่อ complexity ของ
circuit เพิ่มขึ้น นี่คือที่ที่เราต้องการอยู่ เรากำลังอยู่ที่นี่กับวิธีแบบคลาสสิกและควอนตัมประมาณ
เท่ากันสำหรับบางแอปพลิเคชัน และ error correction อาจเหมาะสมที่สุดและ scale ได้ดีมาก
เราแค่ยังไม่ถึงตรงนั้น ในระหว่างนี้เราจะโฟกัสที่ error mitigation และไปถึงพื้นที่
quantum utility โดยเร็วที่สุด และโดยการใช้ error mitigation หลายแบบซึ่งเรา
จะเรียนรู้ในซีรีส์นี้ เรามุ่งหาพื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันที่ใช้ quantum utility ได้เร็ว ๆ นี้ และนั่น
คือหัวใจของคอร์สนี้จริง ๆ เรามีเครื่องเหล่านี้ เราคิดว่ามันสามารถทำวิจัยที่น่าสนใจมาก
แล้วเราใช้มันได้อย่างไร? ในส่วนสุดท้ายของตอนนี้ มาพูดถึงพื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันสำหรับ
Quantum Computing เชิงปฏิบัติกันสั้น ๆ มีสามสาขาหลักที่เราคิดว่าตื่นเต้นและต้องการค้นหาทางสำหรับ Quantum
utility อย่างแรกคือการจำลองธรรมชาติ นี่เกี่ยวกับการจำลองปฏิกิริยาระดับโมเลกุลหรืออะตอม และ
มีความสำคัญมากสำหรับวิทยาศาสตร์วัสดุและเคมี ด้วยเหตุผลที่พูดถึงก่อนหน้า เราคิดว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
จะทำสิ่งนี้ได้ดีกว่าคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกมาก ถัดไปคือ search and
optimization อัลกอริทึมหลักที่น่าสนใจที่นี่เรียกว่า QAOA ซึ่งเป็น hybrid classical-quantum algorithm QAOA ใช้
คอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกเพื่อ train และหา optimal parameter สำหรับ quantum circuit และหวังว่าจะทำ
สิ่งนี้ได้มีประสิทธิภาพกว่าที่คอมพิวเตอร์เพียงเครื่องเดียวทำได้ สุดท้ายมีคณิตศาสตร์และการประมวลผลข้อมูลที่มีโครงสร้าง ควอนตัม
เก่งมากในการหาโครงสร้างในข้อมูลที่รกรุงรัง ซึ่งคุณหรือฉันหรือคอมพิวเตอร์ทั่วไปอาจมองไม่เห็น
อะไรเลย quantum machine learning มีความหวังในพื้นที่นี้ และเราต้องการใช้มันสำหรับงานเช่น feature
extraction และ pattern recognition มันเป็นช่วงเวลาที่น่าตื่นเต้นมากสำหรับพวกเราที่ทำงานใน
สาขา quantum computing ครั้งแรกในประวัติศาสตร์ที่เราสามารถเริ่มสำรวจพื้นที่ของการคำนวณที่อยู่เกิน
ขอบเขต classical computing พวกคุณที่ดูนี้อาจมีบทบาทคล้ายกับผู้บุกเบิกยุคแรกของ
การคำนวณ และพวกเขาไม่มีความคิดเลยว่าสิ่งที่จะตามมาคืออะไร T.J. Watson ของ IBM แม้กระทั่งพูดอย่างโด่งดังว่าเขาคิดว่ามี
ตลาดสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์แค่สองหรือสามเครื่องเท่านั้น และโอ้โห เขาผิดมากเลย
เราทุกคนคือผู้บุกเบิกยุคแรกของการคำนวณนั้น แต่ในสาขาใหม่ของ quantum computing และควอนตัมมักถูก
เปรียบกับ classical computing ว่าเป็นสิ่งที่แตกต่างโดยพื้นฐานและมักแข่งขันกัน แต่
เป้าหมายของการบรรยายแนะนำนี้คือหวังจะโน้มน้าวว่าจากมุมมองภาพรวม เราสามารถมองเห็น quantum
computing เป็นเพียงบทถัดไปในเรื่องราวการคำนวณที่ยาวนาน มันเป็นธรรมชาติของมนุษย์ที่จะค้นหาวิธีใหม่
ในการคำนวณและใช้ประโยชน์จากพลังของโลกธรรมชาติ และหาวิธีใช้มัน เราทำสิ่งนี้มา
หลายศตวรรษแล้ว Quantum Computing มอบเครื่องมือใหม่ในความพยายามนี้ และขึ้นอยู่กับเราที่จะค้นพบวิธีใช้
พลังที่มันมอบให้เรา ในบทเรียนถัดไปในซีรีส์ เราจะพูดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับระบบ 100 qubit
และให้ภาพรวมของ Qiskit ซึ่งเป็น quantum software SDK ของเรา และวิธีโต้ตอบกับเครื่องเหล่านี้ได้ดีที่สุดตอนนี้ ขอบคุณที่
ดู และเจอกันครั้งหน้า